Welcome to MIT's Autonomous Robotics
Team Arcturus
Arcturus!
Arcturus was just founded in 2022 but we'vealready made waves. During our first year as a
team in the robo boat competition Arcturus camein third place in the design portion and fourth
place in the autonomous challenge. This seasonwe're building two boats and a submarine all of
which will be autonomous. We're looking to competein Robo Boat 2023 in Sarasota Florida and the NordChallenge
in Trondheim Norway. Our missionis to provide undergraduates with practical
hands-on experience engineering large systems.Arcturus presents an incredible opportunity
for students to learn the fundamentals
of applied engineering and manufacturing
through Arcturus students are able to
gain engineering experience outside
of the classroom while learning to work
with others and guide their own projects
My name is Audrey and I'm the captain of
Arcturus.
Arcturus has split into threeseparate sub teams: mechanical, navigations, and electrical. Let's meetthem now
Hi I'm Jessica and I'm Jared and we're
the mechanical design team leads, of all themechanical systems as well as the structure ofthe hull
Our general workflow starts with designparts and On Shape which is a cloud-based software
that allows us to collaborate throughout thedesign process of the boat. From there we move on to
assembly and fabrication, we use a couple of tools like 3D printing, milling and laser printing. This allows us to create custom parts for us to test and iterate.
Hi everyone my name is Herbie, I'm a master's student and I lead the navigation sub team.
We're responsible for all the software
that goes on the boat and we're split into severalsub teams-- perception, path planning and mapping, andembedded
We primarily use ROS, the Robot OperatingSystem which is a middleware software commonlyused for robotics
Hi my name is Ansel and I'm
one of the electronics leads for MIT Arcturus
we deal with the entire electrical subsystemfor the boat. Starting from the early design
stages we go in and develop all of the smallersubsystem circuits, getting a test rig set up
to verify them on the bench and then we
integrate them into the vessel at large
once it's all hooked up we do a full vehiclesystems test and that's our final step
from late night sleepovers watching SharkBoy andLavagirl to Robo parties at every test launch we
know that building is always more fun in goodcompany. We're growing rapidly and just this
year our little family has tripled in size to 40members. We're continuing to learn more and more
each day and we couldn't be more excited to showoff all of our hard work at competition this year
[Music]